I don't want to lose my hair from chemo, but a cold cap seems risky with the two where so near my hairline.
Are there other practices protocol supplements that will help me keep my hair?
No, not really.
The reason why you lose your hair with chemo is because chemo is going to be attracted to more rapidly replicating cells.
And it's more attracted to the cancer.
But there are other cell lines in your body that's the catch 22 that are more rapidly replicating like your hair follicles like your immune system.
So it's, you know, we've talked about this before that the cold cap kind of thing is really the only thing that's shown a whole lot of my ability as far as helping people keep their hair and it's still.
So, you know, not like that great to keep working either.
And then you got to look at your putting your head on a really cold ice, is that good for your brain?
I don't know, maybe it is, it's anti-inflammatory maybe.
But also the idea of cold therapy during IVs, are there other things to decrease the chance of neuropathy in my hands and feet?
Well, you know, the neuropathy in your hands and feet and further abuse on your body, not just your hair follicles after chemotherapy is after 48 hours be jutting the eye and pull away every day.
So that will help hold that out.
The neuropathy in your hands and feet is because the the the caustic chemicals of chemotherapy damage your peripheral nerves.
And the damage of those large diameter diameter a ferrets which carry paid and tingly and things are what are damaged and that's why when you get dialed for those nerves you end up with neuropathy.
If cold repels, Kibo might heat draw it.
Well, cold doesn't repel Kibo.
So, cold decreases circulation and heat will increase circulation.
So, heads to question, you know, back here, where where the person's talking about where it was.
This one with the swallowing at the product land and the person and the radiologist saying about a world compress on it, I think the radiologist thinking world compress trying to get low, live low and haven't get flowing.
But typically, let's say you spray your ankle, what do you do when you spray your ankle, you don't you don't, you know, put heat on it.
I mean, it would just blow up like a bloated you just be dyed and paint you put ice on it.
And the idea is that ice decreases the inflammation ice will decrease the blood flow because it's the blood flow to the area that then will leak different cytokines and immune particles to.
And it hits to me that fires this inflammatory reaction.
So, the idea of using cold is your decreasing blood flow to the scalp.
Therefore, you're not repelling the Kibo, but you're decreasing the circulation.
The Kibo is circulating through your blood vessels.
So, if you can decrease the circulation to that area, you're going to.
Hence, decrease the amount of Kibo to that area.
By the heating paint on my deck during the IVs help pull the Kibo to the tumors.
It's not necessary and it might cause swelling.
So, if you're oncologist doesn't recommend that I wouldn't recommend it.
Never heard anybody using heat at the site of the cancer to to increase the circulation to the cancer.
I don't think that's what's recommended.